So what's an incubator?
So, incubators have been around for
a long time.
Idea Lab, back in the early 2000s and
1990s was one of the first ones.
And what incubators are,
it's a group or kind of an organization
that has their own ideas, but
they need teams to build those ideas.
So in a sense what you're doing in
an incubator is you're going to work for
a holding company that has ideas and
you're going in building those ideas.
Now if the ideas take off and
that business becomes successful,
then they spin out and
then they become a private company.
But initially, you're going to work for
somebody else.
You're working on their idea, and
you're trying to get to a point where
it can eject from this mother ship.